hello everyone this game was actually a
suggestion from a subscriber and he
asked if I could show the oldest chess
game ever recorded and well this is
considered to be the oldest chess game
ever recorded and by the oldest chess
game I mean a chess game that was played
by the rules that we use today and at
chaturanga or shut around or you know
the previous version of chess where you
could castle
you know after you castle you could
choose if you want your rook and f1 or
an e1 so this is mod modern chess rules
the exact same we use today and this
game is actually called the chess game
of love as this game was actually part
of a poem and I will put a description
I'll link in the description below where
you can watch the game and as you read
the poem because every move made in this
game is actually a part of the poem and
every move follows the poem so this is
actually a chess game between Venus and
Mars as the poem poem goes I do suggest
you you read the poem so we have e 4 and
D 5 we have the Scandinavian defense we
have eat capture sandy 5 Queen captures
on d5 and yeah I forgot to say this was
played in 1475 in Valencia and Spain we
have Knight to c3 saw the Scandinavian
defense and well black captured with the
Queen and if I we have Knight to c3 now
gaining a tempo on the Queen Queen to d8
and we have a Bishop to c4
we have Knight to f6 Knight to f3 and
the Bishop to g4 immediately pinning
that night h3 we have Bishop captures on
f3 and now Queen captures on f3 and
already you can see that white is what
is a better player here as he is leading
and development and like is someone
behind and what is also threatening to
capture on b7 here and black probably
should the defend this would move like
c6 or maybe maybe even Knight to c6 but
c6 would be better to avoid any Knight
to b5 ideas but here black played east 6
and well what are this is a blunder or
maybe this is some sort of a weird
gambit doesn't really matter but the
white played queen capture some bees
attacking the roof so we have knight
Knight B to d7 another queen defends the
rook and we have at night the b5 now
threatening Knight captures on c7
forking the king and the rook so we have
roped the c8 defending this and now
Knight captures on a7 attacking that we
rockin c8 black plays Knight to b6 and
we have not captured on c8 and Knight
captures on c8 so why does up the
exchange here we have d4 by white and
Knights the d6 with an attack on the
Queen and here white plays Bishop to b5
with check we have nice capture somebody
fun and the queen capture some b5 with
again with check and Knight to d7 now
protecting and here white plays d5 he
wants to open up the position as the
black king is still in the center we
have each captures on d5 and our Bishop
to e3 developing we have Bishop to d6
and rook to d1 we have Queen to f6 rook
captures on d5 and the Queen to g6 now
threatening this Jeep on and also this C
point both depends on what white place
and here well white played Bishop to f4
now inviting black to capture this
bishop and well like does captured is
Bishop Bishop captures on f4 and we have
Queen captures on d7 King to f8 and of
course now Queen to d8 with checkmate so
yeah you don't have to realize that this
game was played in 1475 and I have no
reference on what the strengths of the
players were or if this game was even
played or was it just composed for a
poem but if if this game was actually
played we can pretty much assume that if
you if today you could somehow go to
1475 you would be considered a
grandmaster there if you were at least a
1600 player let's say so yeah this is
the first recorded chess game by the
modern rules that we use today and it
was a battle of Mars and the Venus and I
do I do suggest that you check out the
link in the description and check out
the game while reading the poem as the
make much more sense than when you
simply analyze them as a chess game so
this is this is the game the oldest game
ever played I hope you hope you enjoyed
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here I thank y'all for
watching and I will see you soon